well the i-team following the aftermath
in the death of zappos ceo and
entrepreneur tony shea
two lawsuits making their way right
through court claiming
money owed as part of shea's enormous
estate
but could the public spotlight on one of
the wealthiest men in the valley
have been prevented the i-team's david
charns getting us answers tonight
companies properties and more all owned
by the late tony shea
all estimated to be worth more than 800
million
there's always ways to think bigger or
think differently in the months since
shea's unexpected death two lawsuits
focus on all that wealth
and who may be entitled to some of it
the process unfolding out in the open
because shea had no will it's surprising
and then it's not because we see it
happening all the time
shane jasmine young is an estate
attorney based here in las vegas
i'm sure he didn't realize that this is
probably you know the results that were
that this would be the result
of not having any planning but it is
unfortunately for
for his family and other people that
were in his life lawsuits filed in clark
county by shea's longtime
friend and assistant mimi pham claims
she's owed part of shea's quote
vast fortune for work on shea's behalf
according to one lawsuit the duo was so
close that shea used pham's cell phone
as his own
and the pair had the same address on
their driver's licenses
pham's work according to the lawsuits
partly involves businesses in park city
utah
and a documentary film company all of
these people are going to come out
of the woodwork and say oh well you know
tony promised me this i've got this
contract we had this agreement
and it's already started to snowball
just last week
the i-team reported shea's family was
exploring the sale of nearly 100
downtown properties
one zappos headquarters is worth 20
million dollars alone
according to the most recent assessment
and because shea didn't have
contingencies in place for what would
happen to his money
if and when he died everyone has to have
the opportunity to be able to come
forward
and make claims in this public process
shea was worth a lot of money but young
says any estate worth more than 100 000
has to go through probate unless you
create what's called a revocable living
trust
think of it like a gatekeeper of your
wealth when you're gone
to say who will benefit from your death
unfortunately a lot of us just don't
think of it
whether we're super wealthy or not young
estimates the process over shay's estate
could take
years and she says because there was no
revocable trust
nearly half of that wealth will go right
to taxes lawyers representing those
names in those suits declined to comment
pending the ongoing litigation
i'm david charns 8 news now you can see
all of the i-team's reports on the
investigation into shea's death and
also what we know about his wealth right
now on eight newsnow.com and
inside our free app also find a link to
how you can help get
your prepared your assets to prevent any
kind of headaches later